[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم
الكريم لن يقول ان العلاقات الروسيه
الغربيه وصلت الى مرحله المواجهه لندن
تشدد على ضروره عدم استخدام اي محادثات
سلام بشان الحرب في اوكرانيا كغطاء لي
عاده تسلح روسيا وكيا افتتهم بوتين بعدم
القدره على التفاوض وبرغبته في الاستلام
على الاراضي الاوكرانيه اطباء بريطانيون
يقدمون علاجا رائدا لنوع الفتاك من سرطان
الدم حيث تعافت اول فتاه مصابه بسرطان
الدم الليثوي الحاد بعد خضوع لعلاج بتقنيه
التعديل الوراثي للخلايا المناعيه والذي
وصفه علماء بانه العلاج الاكثر تطورا وغير
تركيا على مواقع ما تعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه في رفي الحسكه وحلب انقره
تؤكد لموسكو ضروره القضاء على من وصفتهم
للارهابيين على طول الحدود مع سوريا وادي
عنقي 30 كلم بعد تحقيق المنتخب المغربي
تاهلا تاريخيا لنصف نهائي بطوله كاس
العالم بفوزه على البرتغال المنتخب
الفرنسي واصل حمله الدفاع بنجاح ويزيح
المنتخب الانجليزي من دور الثمانيه ليضرب
موعد مع اسود الاطلس في نصف النهائي
الى اللقاء